[Music]
kevin stefanski the browns coach talking
about receiver odell beckham jr he was
injured most of last year developed a
hernia during training camp that plagued
him all year long jarvis landry was also
injured for much of the year they're
healthy for now you know they all go
into the off-season and training camp
they're ready to go when it's time to
start but then they go out and they
start getting reps and they start
getting hit and they start getting hurt
again but assuming they can stay healthy
what's more likely that obj and jarvis
landry are a top three receiver duo or
their tantrums outnumber their touchdown
total
um
i would say they're gonna be well let's
let's let's do a quick back of the
napkin who are the who's who else is out
there for top three wide receiver duo
off the top mike evans and chris goblin
mike evans and chris guy kevin's and
chris codwin you could say probably
deandre hopkins and larry fitzgerald or
uh
christian jones or calvin ridley
yeah okay i'm sure we're missing someone
very very obvious here that people are
going to get really upset at
we did the draft earlier in the week i
but that was you know anything more than
a day ago i've already forgotten let's
see here we go i've got
uh
uh tyree kill and sammy watkins how can
we forget that oh that's yup yup michael
thomas and emmanuel sanders
i'm gonna say i'm gonna say that they're
gonna have i'm gonna say they're gonna
be a top three wide receiver duo i'm i'm
bullish on the browns this year i think
they did some stuff with their offensive
line i you know
the the the coaching staff i just think
baker is gonna be
he's gonna have a step forward last year
was humbling for him i think all those
guys like you see it when you have so
much talent and you have a season like
they had last year i think everyone has
to wake up and everyone gets a little
bit of humble pie and you see that the
following year where that talent finally
shines through so i would i'm gonna go
with they're gonna be a top three wide
receiver uh duo
and and there won't be many tantrums in
cleveland this year
and you make a good point because even
though last year was regarded as an
unsuccessful season for the browns they
still were not horrible it was just the
bar was too high they did a horrible job
of managing expectations freddie
kitchens was not suited to be a head
coach now some would say that the browns
should have hired josh mcdaniels instead
of kevin stevansky but i think stefanski
has been more groomed for this job than
kitchens ever was kitchens fell into an
offensive coordinator position for half
a season it worked
the quarterback liked him so let's make
him the head coach and see what happens
well what happened was it didn't work
this year i think they are in position
to fulfill the expectations because
they're lower and they can exceed that
bar and everybody in cleveland can be
really happy about it the jets started
one and seven last year and finished six
and two there's been a lot of chatter
about safety jamal adams wanting out
there was an item in the new york daily
news earlier this week suggesting that
adam gase the head coach of the team is
the reason why jamal adams wants out
offensive lineman alex lewis took to
social media yesterday to debunk that to
push back against it and got pretty
aggressive about this concept of gase
being the reason adams wants out you
know when it boils down to it here's the
thing
adams was trying to get a contract with
the jets and he didn't want out until he
didn't get the contract that he wanted
so if he'd gotten the contract he'd
wanted he would have stayed ipso facto
this doesn't feel like a situation where
he just hates the coach and wants out if
they give him what he wants
he's fine and greg williams defensive
coordinator yesterday talking to
reporters trying to do what he can to
extend an olive branch to jamal adams i
mean the bottom line is they're going to
offer him whatever they offer him and
he's going to want whatever he wants
what's more likely he's traded to
another team or he's on a jets team that
is at or above 500 and fighting for a
playoff spot come december
hmm
ah i feel like he's just gonna be traded
i you know
this is one of those situations mike i
the jalen ramsey situation last year
changed my perspective on it because i
was watching you know watching how that
unfolded the entire time i'm saying to
myself
when you have talent like a jalen ramsey
ramsey or jamal adams teams just don't
let that talent walk out the door just
because a guy is disgruntled for you
know a period of time doesn't mean they
can't figure it out because at the end
of the day if you produce and produce at
a high level and you're an exceptional
player usually the team will eventually
pay
what you want and and everything will
kind of work out watching jaylen ramsey
get traded though
makes me think that now this is a a
league where you know if if a guy is not
happy
he might be able to get traded right
away even
regardless of regardless sorry people
get mad when you say irregardless
regardless of his talent level so jamal
adams well he should be a jet and the
jets should figure out a way to keep him
i actually think that maybe this isn't
going to work out and they will trade
him and and go with draft capital we
talked about this last week mike
when you have a front office that didn't
draft jamal adams that changes things
even though he's a great player even
though he's you know one of the top
players in his positions if you didn't
draft him you don't have that same
loyalty to him and you say well we can
go get draft picks that can be my guys
if we go trade him
they uh they teach you irregardless at
wisconsin is that where you pick that up
i hate i i mean it's just you know what
is it idiom what is that what is it
idiom kind of like you you're i think
i think idiot i think idiot is the yeah
that's the right term here's the thing
to keep in mind right
if they're going to trade jamal adams
i i don't think you can after laramie
tunsil last year and then jalen ramsey i
think you can trade for a guy without
getting him signed to a long-term deal i
think that's a mistake and i think teams
recognize that so in this season of
uncertainty are you going to have all
those planets lined up just right where
you give significant compensation at the
jets to get from all adams and then you
pay him a large amount of money at a
time when there's so much uncertainty
about everything for next year what's
the salary cap going to be what are we
going to be able to afford what are
these draft picks really worth i i i
think there's too many moving parts and
then maybe once jamal adams settles down
and perhaps greg williams is going to be
the guy to do it that he realizes i just
need to go forward and let's figure out
my future after this season so i'm going
to pick even though as a week ago i
figured there's no way to fix this i
think that by the time we get to july 28
folks are going to realize on both sides
they got to find a way to make it work
all right last one and very important
very important
more likely that coach doug
doug coach doug duggar 10 coach gus
duggerton wins a national championship
with toledo or it's exposed that you're
not really playing on the hardest level
on the game what's more likely
okay so you i'm putting you in the camp
uh of all these losers and haters
that all you do all day is think about
what i'm doing and the level of
difficulty i show the level of
difficulty during the game
five times five times during the game
i'll go and show it to the people and
they still think that i'm not playing at
the highest level so but wait no wait
that's not hard that's not hard to do
when the games are pre-recorded and you
can go back
in the false footage that's true that's
fair and then also when you have a lag
switch
so you can just hit a button and have
everything mess up and then change
everything the conspiracy theories
surrounding gus duggerton
are some of my favorite
uh moments on the internet in the last
three months i swear to you mike the
people that are in my twitch chat stream
if we could harness the brain power we
would have already found a vaccine for
coronavirus that's how smart
well uh you know and it just shows you
what the thirst is right now for
anything that feels remotely competitive
and how badly we want to be able to
watch something that isn't scripted that
isn't
pre-planned that is actual competition
where no one knows the outcome which uh
again i don't know why they're watching
the the uh the rigged games that you're
playing but still it's close enough it
feels like a real game until you
intentionally lose and or otherwise
you're not playing on the hardest
possible level all right let's take a
break when we return coach matt role of
the carolina panthers used a bit of
hyperbole when discussing his new
franchise quarterback or he hopes he's a
franchise quarterback we'll discuss that
next year on pft live
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports